I'll tell you this right now maybe you
know how I know I did it make it I'll
let you know when I didn't make it Oh a
hundred percent safe I will be on this
podcast and I'll say me you know how I
know is because if somebody asked me
they go hey David what amount of money
would you take the suck a dick I had
that number in my head that's how you
know I did it because I still would suck
a dick for a certain amount of money
that number is pretty [ __ ] surprising
Edie what is this what is the number
what is the number amount that you would
take for money to suck a dick man that
would have to be as a heterosexual male
as a heterosexual male if you're not a
heterosexual male doesn't count when you
lie that you don't have a number you
just a [ __ ] liar
everybody has a [ __ ] number um [ __ ]
man like it definitely is greater than a
million because I feel like in this day
and age of million is nothing right that
you have value 1000 let's start a
Kickstarter David so start a Kickstarter
right thousand dollar 30,000 and a slice
of bacon and a slice of bacon uncooked
Wow you don't even ask that is horrific
Lee love I feel like it got even lower
than the last time we talked yo you have
any idea how many how much it cost on
this podcast you understand that $50,000
would change that in life right now
that's true you know as you get older
you got more expenses and you know you
need more money tell you something else
man let's say I suck the dick for a
million right now advice I can't believe
you suck the dick yeah you know blah
blah blah but let me tell you something
real quick all right when my kid is
looking at me with his little Tonka
truck toys and he goes dad what did you
do for this dad he struggled that he
[ __ ] suck the dick for you ya or
daughter yeah I'll tell you this right
now sigh daddy are you gay
I am not gay if I was it would have been
a lot easier yeah however for your
college tuition you because I love you
you can read because I put a penis in my
mouth yeah and I'll put it to you like
that don't you
talk back to me don't you ever say don't
you ever say I didn't sacrifice for you
if a kid hears is if the kid hears those
words come out of his dad's mouth
you got nothing to say at that and I'm
tell you this right now III have rules
to this to I've actually thought about
this Mike tonight rules all right I will
I will do it to a man mm-hmm
who is cleanly shaven okay I don't want
sea urchin spines on my eyes and the
watch the dick has to be washed like
freshly showered freshly showered you
have to get if you're uncircumcised you
have to you have to you you you
[ __ ] you better you better make
sure that that turtleneck is clean yeah
and then after that you get about five
swipes
wah-wah-wah-wah okay okay but do you
gotta make him nut nope no no it's just
sucking dick it's sucking dick Wow
that's not too bad I mean it's you know
as a straight fight I call the five
wants and I want my [ __ ] in cash untaxed
okay I want it in cash
Kenny like set a stipulation we're like
you got to make eye contact with him he
could record it yeah you could record it
but when fear accords it yeah that goes
at the 55,000 he cannot distribute it
unless I make pocket all right guys you
could distribute it but I guess 70%
profit you get 30% okay and I want two
slices of cooked bacon in your [ __ ]
face that's a low expectations I'm
telling you man see this this is this is
business wanna learn from the best you
heard it here you take thousand dollars
and then you take that money you start
your own clothing company zactly that's
right yeah and because you sucked a dick
for a you'll work extra hard yo know
you'll make sure that dog does not go to
waste
exactly dude I got no shame man I'm all
about the future
well fifty thousand dollars probably
what does he care Mike you know no not
at all that'll buy you like maybe a year
I changed my number I want it to be a
hundred thousand on the fly man I'll
tell you this right now that's luscious
ass lips I understand why she's luscious
yeah you know use the chapstick go make
sure that many chaps
easy beautiful with a lot of five one
five wants all five whomp your dick
right now I'll tell you what man there
is no [ __ ] way I'm sucking dick for
$50,000 100,000 hundred and fifty
thousand though it has to be a million
plus if I'm gonna do yes it has to be am
it because it has to secure not only me
but my family you know like like my
parents you know my sister like I can't
even buy a house with a million it's
what I mean dude I changed my number
dude I understand I thought I was living
in the Philippines for a second I
thought I was I thought I thought my
name is r.j. in the Philippines and I
was going to buy a place there and I was
going to live with my family over there
and I thought I was going to be there
forever but I was my new number is two
million two million because I need the
first million to buy a house and then
after that and I probably would get yeah
then I'd be happy yeah yeah I don't know
man even 2 million I feel like it's too
low I never forget whatever that guy's
asking for it you'll never forget either
you'll always look back to the first
time you got the best [ __ ] of your
life I wonder if there is a dude out
another heterosexual male who's like so
[ __ ] ballin and so bored that he's
willing to make like an offering like
that like yo man if you out there right
now if you're watching there's a dude
out there right now
oh you know what I think back the
recording part just getting real getting
real real for two million dollars if you
get that [ __ ] I will give you five
whomps on your dick right now change my
life 2 million dollars cash you you you
come at me Harry Persian man you come at
me Abdul changed my parents life changed
my life right now my life I don't think
so man
think about it do like you get a house
you still got to pay property taxes and
all that alright three minutes [ __ ]
pretty ridiculous thank you for this
conversation as if I didn't have the
delivery 50,000 I sure would have been a
steal I bet you a lot of people were
like dupe we could probably go fund me
this move faster and you would have a
second dude stick yeah you know what it
can't no go fund me because I want it
cash no go fund me I want that [ __ ] in
[ __ ] cash dude yeah of course dude I
wouldn't want to [ __ ] worry US
dollars u.s. dollar bills or 50,000
pounds which is more than American
dollar I can't believe you started at 50
that that's I don't know hey you know
any [ __ ] expensive this was that's
true this [ __ ] will just tell hey this
is dope dope I will tell you this people
don't understand man this is not a logo
this is an art piece I had commissioned
an artist to do this [ __ ] was our man
like this was amazing work that he did
and he paid a pretty penny for it that's
why he's he's stupid he's double you
know why you're dumb dude I would have
sucked your dick for it oh and that [ __ ]
is worth three million dollars